we have a regular hexagon with area
equal to three and we need to calculate
the Shaded area of the parallelogram
which is formed by a vertex and a
midpoint of opposite sides here's one
way to solve the problem let s be half
the side of the hexagon and let H be the
height of the hexagon then the area of
the parallelogram is equal to H times s
now divide the hexagon into six
equilateral triangles where each
equilateral triangle has height equal to
0.5 h and has a base that's equal to 2s
each equilateral triangle has area
that's equal to 0.5 HS so six times that
area will be equal to 3 HS and that's
equal to 3 which means HS is equal to
one that's one way to solve the problem
here's a fun way to solve the problem
we'll shift the area of the
parallelogram into a rectangle then
we'll move these right triangles to the
other equilateral triangles so in total
the Shaded area is two of the
equilateral triangles out of a total of
six so the Shaded area is one third of
the hexagons area which is equal to one